so I'm Marcia in Warren I'm a professor
of anthropology like dr. Kathryn pantry
brick my good colleague here and we're
both medical anthropologists and I had
basically spent my career working in the
Middle East and so I'm going to take you
to the Middle East but then I'm going to
bring you back from the Middle East to
the Arab American world and talk about
Arab refugees who have been resettled
and have been here for a while and some
of the challenges they face and honey
Malathi is not in the room that I see
but I appreciate his coming before me
and talking about Aleppo Syria I am
wearing a silk scarf made in Aleppo
Syria in a silk company that is no
longer in existence and I just want to
say that Syria was one of the most
beautiful countries in the world and
much of it has been destroyed and I just
want to speak to Syria and the beauties
that was Syria okay I have a book coming
out this fall from Stanford University
Press called America's Arab refugees
vulnerability and health on the margins
and I'm going to give you pieces of that
book you know sort of pieces from it and
my talk is going to be very political
because I want to talk about
responsibility for conflict you know who
bears that responsibility how do we get
to the place where we've gotten in parts
of the Middle East and I'm focusing
particularly on Iraq today but let's
just begin with the world at war there
are about 55 violent conflicts 13 our
recent started since 2011 and four of
them are high casualty conflicts with
more than 10,000 deaths occurring
annually in both 2014 and 2015 and
unfortunately three of these high
fatality wars are in the Middle Eastern
region in the Middle East and North
Africa Afghanistan Iraq and Syria we
hear a lot about Syrian refugees and we
serve are focusing on Syria but
Afghanistan and Iraq continue to be
plagued by very severe violence and many
of the refugees in Europe are Afghan or
Iraqi not just Syrian I want to point
that out and my point here two of these
wars were authorized by the US Congress
in Iraq and Afghanistan 2011 was a
critical moment in that President Barack
Obama
that the war in Iraq was over on
December 18 2011 presumably all the u.s.
ground troops were removed from the
country of Iraq but that was the same
year 2011 which was the beginning of the
so-called Arab Spring all the protest
movements have started and in the
aftermath we know that we can't really
call an Arab Spring it was a moment of
insurgency and protest it had started
that hopefully and aspirationally and
has ended up in some very bad outcomes
with the initiation of three new Middle
Eastern wars in Syria Libya Yemen and
ultimately I'm going to talk to you
about the emergence of Isis foreign
policy magazine in 2015 so two years ago
said that there are ten wars to watch in
the world today and four of them
including some of the most important are
in the Middle East the list includes
this combined war this sort of merged
war between Syria Iraq and the Islamic
state which is sort of between those two
countries and this is what they called
the top war in the world today
Afghanistan dr. Sandra Brooke and Mark
Germann have worked in Afghanistan but
the Afghan war is now sixteen seventeen
years old
many commentators are calling it a
permanent war it probably is a war that
will never go away Yemen the forgotten
more Saudi Arabia and its Gulf coalition
including the u.s. because we are
military allies of Saudi Arabia we are
bombing the heck out of Yemen there is a
gulf war going on that we don't hear
much about but it's a major humanitarian
crisis and Libya Muammar Qaddafi was
removed but there is a civil war going
on in Libya that's involving parts of
the Saharan region so these are four top
ten wars in the world today I'm going to
talk mostly about Iraq and what I call
the ongoing Iraq war I should really say
it's more like 37 years of suffering
because it really dates back to 1980 or
1979 the bath party was a social
democratic party that came into power in
Iraq and Saddam Hussein became the
leader of the bath party in 1979 he was
a war monger for sure a year after his
election or his becoming pres
he plunged Iraq into a very long almost
decade-long war with Iran which is
considered to be one of the longest
conventional wars between two countries
in modern history with up to a million
people killed
it ended in 88 two years later he
invaded the neighboring country of
Kuwait beginning the first Gulf War it
was only a 6-week war but the UN
sanctions period that followed lasted
for thirteen years where Iraq was
sanctioned and people could not import
things into that country including food
medicine and basic supplies it was very
difficult for Iraq right after America
left Kuwait in Iraq the u.s. backed a
failed Shia insurgency the Shia Muslims
from southern Iraq were asked to rise up
in an empty Fatih against Saddam Hussein
they did but they failed and by 1992 we
see the first wave of Iraqi refugees
fleeing through Saudi Arabia where they
often ended up in refugee camps under
horrible conditions for five six seven
years about 80,000 Iraqis came in that
first wave in 1996 the UN realizing the
Iraqi citizens were suffering started an
oil for food program we give you food
Iraq you give us your oil and then
September 11th happened and you know
Iraq was blamed a Saddam Hussein was
blamed by george w bush and so after
invading Afghanistan in 2001 the u.s.
started its operation in Iraq called
Operation Iraqi Freedom the so-called
second Gulf War in twice 2006 Saddam
Hussein was executed but things are so
unstable in Iraq that there was a
so-called US troop surge to try to sort
of make things a little calmer to reduce
the casualties of heavy casualties and
by this time there were so many Iraqis
trying to flee the country that US
ambassador Ryan Crocker urged President
George W Bush to start admitting your
Waukee refugees back to the US
especially those who had helped US
forces as translators guides
drivers and so on and so in this period
beginning in 2007 we see the second
major wave of Iraqi refugees coming into
the country and it's been ongoing I'm
going to show you the figures and
presumably things ended the war was
supposed to be over in 2011 the u.s.
completed its troop withdrawal but two
years later something called Isis
emerged and declaring itself an Islamic
state in 2014 Isis took over muscle the
second-largest city in Iraq by 2015
the Iraqi army realized that needed to
do something to sort of challenge Isis
in Iraq and so with us support the Iraqi
army launched its offensive to take back
these key cities by 2016 there was
really a full-scale war going on with
Isis and it involved US military support
there are estimated to be at least 5,000
US troops on the ground in Iraq and the
effort to take back Mosul continues
right now as I speak so it is 2017 is
what April 13th 2017 the US war in Iraq
has not ended
okay so started in 2003 its 2017 which
makes it a 14-year war and god only
knows how long it will continue why why
did george w bush intervene in iraq well
purportedly it was to find and destroy
the weapons of mass destruction we know
this was based on false intelligence on
a lie that somehow Saddam Hussein was
responsible for September 11th and so it
was supposedly to increase US security
definitely it was to overthrow Saddam
Hussein who he was a bad guy everybody
realizes he was a very brutal dictator
it was better that he be taken out if
you will but there were other
neoconservative interests at play
including the notion of regime change if
you could sort of create an Iraq that
would be friendly to US interests
especially the oil fields we would have
more oil flowing out of Iraq and
purportedly this is about democracy
building to establish a democratic
regime in Iraq and also to be less of a
threat to Israel so these are there are
all sorts of of reasons
the u.s. wanted to invade Iraq in 2003
but the outcome has been bleak the this
war in Iraq has been condemned by most
political scientists and I'm not a
political scientist but I read the
political science sort of analyses they
say it's probably the worst military
intervention in recent history in recent
American military history it was a
foreign policy failure George W Bush
when he went to war in Iraq did not know
the difference between a Sunni and Shia
masong he admitted it he didn't know
that there were sort of different
branches of Islam and he didn't know
what he was doing the u.s. through its
right behind the Shia and Kurdish
populations of Iraq their minority
populations in the world of you know
sort of the Middle Eastern world and it
was the first time in modern Middle
Eastern history where Shia Muslims who
are the minority sect of Islam were
given power and control in an Arab
country and so we sort of put our
support behind the Shias and sort of the
expense of the Sunnis which is where
Saddam Hussein came from and this has
just unleashed its unseated incredible
sectarian tension and rivalry not only
in Iraq but in Syria and in other parts
of the Middle East it's led to
widespread political instability a
democracy has not been installed in Iraq
it's a very weak and incomplete
democracy and the US war we can say was
really in a way seeded the growth of
Islamic jihadist groups in the country
the u.s. because it created this very
unstable chaotic situation in Iraq
really it became a breeding ground for
groups like al-qaeda knew to affront
Isis and so on so we have to really look
at ourselves and say we did a lot of
this the US government is responsible
for a lot of the bad things that have
happened in Iraq did anybody hear George
W Bush on NPR this morning driving in oh
yes what did he say
no regrets no remorse what he's done in
his post-presidency is to become a great
painter a great oil painter and he has
just issued a book of paintings of Iraq
and Afghan veterans American veterans
who've been wounded and so forth and
that's where he's put his effort he has
not been tried for war crimes he feels
no guilt he thinks it was a good thing
that happened as do many of the people
from his regime so basically it was you
know we haven't retaken responsibility
for what we unleashed in Iraq and I feel
that if you break something you have to
fix it and you have to take
responsibility for the people whose
lives you disrupted and so I'm going to
be talking about that in my book I talk
about all the costs of war for Iraqis
horrible toll the body count is very
high some people estimate that about a
half million Iraqis have died mental
health costs we heard about this morning
a high rates of PTSD anxiety depression
and so on there have been high maternal
and child health costs because
infrastructure has been destroyed and
you know we talked about Hannah you
talked about medical targeting
absolutely happen in Iraq the
destruction of clinics hospitals the
fleeing of Iraqi health care personnel
that's a story that's been documented
horrible environmental health costs in
Iraq there is a radioactive substance
called depleted uranium D U it's been
used extensively by the US military
forces in both of the wars in Iraq and
it has got a very long 4.5 billion year
half-life it is basically radioactive
uranium has been just you know don't in
the environment and so we're beginning
to see high rates of cancer congenital
birth defects and children and I'm going
to talk probably about some of the
reproductive health effects of D U but
today for the rest of time I want to
talk about the Iraqi refugee crisis and
that's really what my book you know if
we go from war you know why what
happened why did people feel that they
need to flee and where did they end up
there have been between the years 2007
when finally the u.s. at okay we need to
start taking
Iraqis again there have been the total I
complained the total is this number
about 125,000 Iraqis have entered the
u.s. about half of those who would like
to be admitted as refugees into the u.s.
and you can see that the numbers have
absolutely increased began very small
1,000 and did you know that like last
year the number of Syrian refugees
admitted I think in 2015 was about that
amount a very very tiny number of Syrian
refugees led into this country so it
started very small then there was a huge
sort of spike got bigger bigger bigger
and backing a bigger here but sort of a
decline and and we don't know what's
going to happen because of our new
regime of President Trump or you know
where did they go the levels of
resettlement they talked about sort of
through settlement levels I am going to
be tough sorry I am going to be talking
about Michigan in red Michigan a poor
state overall has taken in its fair
share sf California in Texas two big
states tiny Connecticut is a good state
to be a refugee by the way but because
it's just a small state we're a small
state the numbers have been small serve
less than a thousand but you know the
whole country 49 of the 50 states have
taken in Iraqi refugees one state which
was the big blank white space on the map
this morning that was shown did anybody
notice that which state is that marker
goes it's the state of Wyoming Dick
Cheney's state has taken zero Iraqi
refugees and in fact apparently no
refugees at all because it's a blank on
the refugee map so there you go Dick
Cheney remember he was an architect of
this whole problem okay well I want to
take you to Michigan I was a professor
at University of Michigan before I came
to Yale and I worked for five years in
the Iraqi and the sort of population of
this place which is called Arab Detroit
by scholars Nabil Abraham and Andrew
Shryock they have published huge thick
edited volumes called Arab Detroit
republished in 2011 but I find this to
be interesting this is
probably a Yemeni woman wearing both the
hijab and niqab or full facial veil but
she's behind an American car because why
a Michigan Detroit Michigan is Motor
City there has been a robust auto
industry there over the years and a lot
of the first arabs who came to Detroit
came there actually long ago in the
early 1900s to work in Henry Ford's
automobile factory so that was sort of
the beginning of the Arab community
there and the Ford Rouge factory which
is Ford's largest auto factory in the
world literally is right there in the
heart of Dearborn which is over the
center of Arab Detroit it's polluting
the smokestacks are often billowing and
literally every time I would drive in I
would just go by the Rouge plant and
then a mile away was the clinic in which
I worked so it's a sort of polluted
industrial kind of landscape there still
it is an enclave that really serves a
large Arab community the highest
estimates that are about 400,000 Arabs
living in Arab Detroit there are Arab
businesses there's a vibrant religious
community and this is actually the
largest mosque in America which happens
to be a Shia Muslim dominated mosque
because Shiah Muslims who are the
minority in the Middle East are the
majority in Arab Detroit because they've
had to flee often as minority Muslims
out of the region and so Arab Detroit is
North America's largest area of ethnic
Enclave and so being in an enclave
community can be comforting when you're
a refugee we've heard about refugee
networks of support and why that's
important to be around your community
and that's really what Detroit offers on
some levels but it has real problems on
the other hand Detroit is America's
poorest big city it has extremely high
poverty rates for a city a metropolitan
area over 200,000 people Detroit itself
I'm going to show you the map the center
of Detroit is predominantly
african-american it ranked first for
poverty more than a third of all Detroit
citizens are impoverished living below
the federal poverty line and overall two
thirds of Detroiters live either in
poverty or in the state
allas asset limited income constrained
though employed they are the working
poor they may have some part-time jobs
they may be working but they are poor
and then you go to the white suburbs of
which there are huge white suburbs
ringing it's a classic example of white
flight it's a wealthy situation out in
the suburbs are only 5% of people live
in poverty and I will tell you I'm going
to show you this next slide this is the
impoverished city center of Detroit it's
predominantly african-american although
there are small Yemeni communities right
in the middle one called Hamtramck this
is the heart of Arab Detroit right here
it's a big suburb of Dearborn and Iraqis
have settled here and up here just on
the margins of the city in these these
sort of areas you go to the lake Lake
Michigan beautiful mansions all around
here all around here it is a rich ring
with a lot of Iraqi Chaldeans they're
Christian Iraqis who've been coming for
many decades and are very wealthy a
wealthy Iraqi population but their
Christian and they sort of disassociate
themselves from the incoming Iraqi
Muslim refugee population so that is a
the situation this is where we're you
know I did my study so most of the
refugees have become citizens because
they came as refugees eighty percent of
Arab Detroiters are naturalized citizens
but look at the poverty levels
eighty-two percent of Iraqi Muslim
families live on incomes household
incomes of less than 30,000 a year which
isn't that the stipend for a graduate
student at Yale okay
thirty thousand okay whole families are
living below that almost all 82 percent
of Iraqi Muslim families
almost half of Iraqi Muslim families
they're live on less than $10,000 a year
I don't know how anybody does that and
it's especially difficult for Arab
female-headed households almost half
living below the poverty line so I was
there as a professor and I for five year
period I went back and forth between Ann
Arbor
Arab Detroit about a 45-minute Drive I
was there I had come back from Lebanon
in 2003 and it was sort of this
Islamophobia was strong my colleagues in
Michigan called it the terror deck of
the decade you know we had the US
invasion of Iraq all of this sort of
post-911 Islamophobia and in the midst
of that the Michigan economy and the
auto industry was in a tailspin downward
the Great Recession as you call happen
in 2008 2009 and by 2013 Detroit had to
declare chapter 9 bankruptcy
it's the largest municipal bankruptcy
it's rough sea in the history of the US
so the city I don't know if anybody's
been in the center of Detroit recently I
can tell you honestly I don't have
pictures but coming back from Lebanon
which is war-torn where there are bullet
holes on buildings and collapsed
buildings if you go into the center of
Detroit it looks like a war took place
there and my young children at that time
said did a war happen here - its
collapsing infrastructure burned out
buildings it is just a scene of
incredible deprivation and that is
Detroit I mean they're trying to rebuild
but it's a very impoverished place so I
was there I did a study in ethnographic
study I worked with almost a hundred
Arab Detroiters 55 men 40 women
sometimes couples together and sometimes
just meant alone and women alone a lot
were Iraqi refugees they were official
refugees and they came from both of the
Iraq Wars from the first Gulf War and
then the newer arrivals coming in in a
second and there were also many Lebanese
Shia Muslim I call them more xl's they
didn't come as official refugees but
they had fled the Civil War and the
10-year Israeli occupation of southern
Lebanon that lasted until the year 2000
so I was seeing this sort of incoming
group of new Iraqi and Lebanese people
fleeing war as well some Yemenis and
Palestinians the Yemenis at that time
didn't have a war in their country but
they do now I have been working on
reproductive health issues my entire
career so I was focusing on reproductive
health problems but I want to say that
overall this is what in medical
anthropology would call a very
structurally
vulnerable population structural
vulnerability is a sort of great
conceptual analytic that's been
forwarded by a very well known medical
anthropologist named Philippe Bourgois
and his colleagues they work mostly with
Latino immigrants in the US but I think
this term structural vulnerability
absolutely applies to the refugee and
sort of you know immigrant Arab
population you're it's about your
position in society
what's your financial status are you
employed are you not do work part time
how much Purdue bring home are you
documented undocumented are you a
refugee and asylum seeker did you
complete school were you able to get
schooling before you left your country
do you speak English
what's your language ability do you have
a home do you have shelter where do you
live
are you food secure and what is your
social network do you have people who
are there for you if you need help and
then they talk about just overall
environments of risk are you living in a
place where there are gunshots where
it's safe where there's police
enforcement where there are no toxins in
the environment where what is your
environment in terms of overall risk are
you profiled by police in your community
so this is sort of their notion of
structural vulnerability and I would
argue that structural vulnerabilities
are profound in Arab Detroit most of the
people that I worked with are not fluent
in English some of the men had become
often the women women spoke no English
they were Arabic speakers only low
levels of education a lot of people fled
before they could complete high school
in Iraq or in their home countries and
when they got to Michigan as you know
the I would say in general those who
worked those men who worked were in what
we would call blue-collar or sort of
low-wage forms of labor like being
Busboys and restaurants or working in
gas stations or being like a mechanic or
working in a factory and overtime with
the five years I was there I saw
increasing rates of unemployment men
were losing jobs because the auto
industry was sinking most of the women
did not work in part because many of
them didn't speak English very few
people had in
it was uh I'm sure you know it was
actually affordable care hadn't even
happened until 2000 when when did a
forbit affordable 2009 it came yeah so
and so people were using cash it wasn't
they didn't have credit cards you know
they were sort of no social safety nets
if a catastrophe happened you were kind
of on your own and I asked people if you
had an emergency do you have family
members here somebody who could help you
because our family members are in the
same situation that we're in you know no
really no there isn't somebody who can
bail us out so people were vulnerable
and I was especially interested in my
study in the Iraqi refugee men who
consistently said their lives were hard
they were under stress most of these men
were political refugees they were ones
who'd often fought on one side or the
other mostly against Saddam Hussein they
had gone through war many had been
tortured or persecuted in the ways that
we heard in the first panel this morning
and so the scene was well I've lived
through the war a lot of it in Arabic
and they told me about what they thought
they'd been exposed to they told me
about all the cancer in Iraq about all
the chemicals about all the destruction
and I have a long section in my book
about depleted uranium but you know they
were exposed to things there and so
ultimately they were reproductively
vulnerable men look at that more than
three-quarters of the men in my study
had serious male infertility problems
and I met them at this place called IVF
Michigan which is the largest IVF
provider in all of Michigan and Ohio
they had a Dearborn office like in the
heart of Arab Detroit where a Lebanese
Shia Muslim physician would come down to
try to have a sort of clinic there for
the poor the poor refugees and the sort
of poor community to come and that's
where I met these people male
infertility just you know could involve
many things low sperm count poor
movement of sperm misshapen sperm or you
may not have any sperm at all in your
ejaculate or there's a sinkhole ago a
cinemas of sperm eeeh which is Hugh
sperm and they don't swim well and so
these are sort of the you know this is
what it is that's male infertility and
it can be very severe or not so severe
there
is this technology this masculine hope
technology called intracytoplasmic sperm
injection it see it's a variant of in
vitro fertilization it was developed in
1991 in Belgium and it is a rather
revolutionary technology where if you
can find any living sperm in a man's
body
including by going into the testicles
with needles I'm doing all of this
needlework to try to get the sperm out
very painful if you can find sperm you
can inject them directly into the human
Oh site and remarkably cause embryos to
be formed and quite remarkably it C has
created now millions of offstring for
men who would otherwise be absolutely
infertile or sterile so it's a rather
you know revolutionary technology but in
the u.s. it costs twelve thousand five
hundred dollars per one cycle and so
these men like they were trying
they were like reproductively agentive
they were coming into the clinic they
said well you know you can do what you
need to to my body you know diagnosed me
treat me they were putting the
reproductive bodies on the line they
wanted to have children part of
rebuilding your life is to be able to
have kids and to rebuild the family that
was lost and they wanted they love their
wives they wanted to have a family but
XT was absolutely unaffordable to most
of these men and there really was
heartbreaking in the five years that I
was there out of all the people that I
worked with only two XE babies were born
both the Iraqi refugee couples that was
it and so some of the men heartbreaking
stories in my book or about men saying I
care for my wife feeling she deserves to
be a mother I'm going to release her she
has the right to have children I'm
divorcing her so that she can be freed
and go and remarry and there were cases
of that as well so I ended up thinking
of these refugees as reproductive
exhales so it was our country the u.s.
forced them to leave Iraq right they
wouldn't be here if it weren't for the
jords the the George HW and then the
George W Bush Wars okay the two wars by
the Bush family they are here most of
them couldn't go back to Iraq they're
unable to return
here they are in America in basically an
inaccessible healthcare system can't
afford us infertility services because
infertility services in the u.s. are
privatized they're seen as elective
they're not part of most health
insurance there's sort of no state
mandate they're not part of the
Affordable Care Act either so if you
want to treat your infertility you have
to do it out of your own pocket and so
x-files forced out of the u.s.
reproductive health care system Dixie
was just a dream it was a mirage for
most of these people and so in my book I
have all these stories I have one about
this guy but I came he'd fought he was a
southern Iraqi Shia Muslim he fought
against Saddam Hussein he fled he was
injured he fled in revenge Saddam
Hussein took his older brother father
four children and disappeared him they
never saw from him again he felt very
guilty for his brother's death came as a
refugee to the US settled in st. Louis
Missouri which is where they placed him
fell in love with an American woman they
were going to move into an apartment
together and the brakes on their u-haul
tractor-trailer didn't function and they
crashed she was automatically killed and
he ended up spending a year in the
hospital completely broken he finally
did some so-called secondary migration
out of Missouri to Arab Detroit where I
met him his family back in Iraq arranged
for him to marry an Iraqi chemistry
teacher a woman from Iraq they met in
Jordan they married they came back to
Michigan and after all of that he
couldn't get her pregnant so he came to
IVF Michigan to figure out what's going
wrong and lo and behold he is a severe
male factor infertility problem they
told him he needed XE they were going to
give him a discount because the Muslim
physician felt very sorry and so out of
charity zakat he would often do big deep
discounts but the discount was to ten
thousand dollars from you know twelve
thousand five hundred and Ibrahim said
you know maybe if it were five thousand
dollars maybe I could eventually earn
the money or borrow the money but ten
thousand dollars never I'll never be
able to afford this thing and so
fortunately his wife loved him he was
actually a very handsome
I have to say but his wife I shouldn't
say that but it was true he you know and
his wife loved him and she said look
it's enough that we had each other and
were out of Iraq you know I have you
here enough for me so it was sort of
poignant but any rate that was there
many stories like this in the book so
that my book is saying you know Arab
refugees resettled the ones who spent I
mean honey you said it takes work wasn't
used 17 years to recreate a life that's
literally what I saw in my study in air
betrayed people who are still struggling
even once who'd come from the first Gulf
War
their health they were living on the
margins literally of Detroit but also on
the margins in terms of Health Access
and so I conclude with a lots of things
I conclude that now we've moved from
Bush now jump forward to Donald Trump
and you know in his presidential
campaign he initiated this new cycle of
Islamophobia he started calling for the
Muslim ban back in 2015-2016 and sadly
Michigan Governor Rick Snyder was one of
the first ones to jump on board that
thinking he was one of more than 30
state governors who declared that they
were not going to let Syrian refugees
enter their states I say that we're in
an unprecedented anti-refugee moment
here that we've heard about all day long
and really there are going to be new
regimes of exclusion as long as Donald
Trump remains president of the u.s. I'm
afraid and I want to say that Arab lives
do matter and America that caused a lot
of the problems in the Arab world must
care thank
I can answer any question yes so we can
take two questions you choose one here
and one here
hello mentioned the structural
vulnerability of Arab refugees did did
your research allow you to see whether
that vulnerability was truly structural
and passed down to there to the next
generation of people that had come as
early refugees from you know prior wars
did with their children similarly
disenfranchised first story in my book
there's a prologue of a young Iraqi
couple they were actually both they came
as children are sort of preteens with
their families in the first Gulf War
they had lived in the Saudi refugee camp
they came and she got educated he
started working she got educated and
they were actually doing quite well by
community standards as a sort of first
you know 0.5 refugee popular sort of
generation but her field they were
struggling still and the father was
trying to get like a retirement a
pension out of Iraq you know he was not
doing well he had a small business and
so they was a long story but they put
everything on the line to do one one
cycle of IVF they did it and then a
catastrophe happened she got severe
ovarian hyperstimulation syndrome ended
up in the hospital with a huge hospital
bill that they had no way to pay for and
she they both so we can't go back to our
parents our parents are basically hardly
hanging on and so even though they were
sort of beginning to like come out of
poverty they actually bought a small
house she had been working you know it
was going well he lost both of his jobs
you know so they were like barely
getting out and then things started
going downhill and there was nobody to
turn to I mean I ask people like can
anybody help you and people often had
nobody that they could turn to because
everybody was kind of in the same
situation and this was the older
of their parents who had come and I saw
this next generation of who'd come as
kids and we're still just not making the
American dream
there were a couple of happy stories in
this book of a few people who did like
one guy he worked in worked he bought a
barber shop he taught himself how to cut
hair and then he was really good at that
and he bought another barber shop you
know so he had two barber shops and he
was he told me he was taking home about
thirty thousand dollars in profit still
that's not a lot of money but that was a
success story for this population and it
wasn't only Iraqis I have to tell you
the Lebanese that I saw they were new
arriving Lebanese Muslims from southern
Lebanon were equally impoverished so it
was it wasn't to the sort of in the
early days before 2001 the book Arab
Detroit that was written the huge
anthology and it was very optimistic it
was called for margins to mainstream
about how the Arab community was doing
so well and some people were opening
businesses and moving out to the burbs
and it was very aspirational then when
they had to reissue it in 2011 it was
called Arab Detroit life in the terror
decade you know just about how things
censor to fallen apart for a lot of
people in that community so it's a
struggling community over the
generations and I hope that the next
generation will be able to sort of move
out of the situation that I described in
the book a fantastic presentation so
good how does the Arab community view
adoption that's one quick question and
the larger question is how would you
compare and contrast American community
in Dearborn and Detroit with let's say
those in the Bern news in outside Paris
and Merlin bacon in Brussels what are
some of the Saleen you know common
features but also distinctions between
these populations
dominant branch of Islam what we call
adoption legal adoption where you can
take a child give it your name give it
your inheritance treat it as if it is
your own biological child is not allowed
there is a system called Kafala which is
foster rich or guardianship legal
guardianship which is allowed but you're
never supposed to give a child your name
the child should always retain the name
that it was and know who it's
genealogical parents are and because of
that adoption is a pretty hard sell
throughout the Sunni Muslim world I've
written a lot about that in my my books
but especially as I work on infertility
but having said that in America I saw
the certain openness people knew that
there was adoption in America and I
talked to people about it like would you
ever consider doing that to get a child
and and some people said you know yeah
how do you do it where do you find out
the information at the end of the book I
actually say they're going to be so many
war orphan children coming out of Syria
Iraq Afghanistan we're going to need to
have Muslim families take in these
children and so that's one of the things
I talked about at the end of the book
but adoption it's a it's a religious
thorny problem which is why people try
hard to do have kids with their own
biological gametes so that's one thing
this sort of the in the sort of areas
around Paris what we've seen in Europe
where you've got these sort of
generations of disaffected youth who can
then be radicalized and turned to Isis
and so forth and we know that that's
what's going on actually a lot of the
people who've done acts in Paris and
Brussels and so forth they're actually
North Africans they're Tunisians and
Moroccans
who are not coming out of Syria Iraq
they're people who grew up in France and
have felt like second-class marginalized
citizens for a long time and so this
sort of dissipation can really greed you
know radicalism if you want to put it
that way I personally did not see that
in the people that I talked with in fact
a lot of people said I'm American this
is my country now I have the rights of
an American citizen there was a sort of
claim
of being American a sort of proudness
that you know I'm here we struggled and
and we're here so no having said that
there was a lot of profile profiling in
this community during the period that I
was working there because you know oh
this is you've got these Arabs they must
be fueling terrorism and because there
are a lot of Shia in this community they
were looking at ties between Shia
Muslims in Dearborn and his a lot in
Lebanon because it's a Shia paramilitary
kind of group and so there are people
getting detained deported it was a
rugged time last decade so you know all
is not well the high proportion of
people living at you said Alice right
and that's a really a road to disinfect
ation and you know this could tend and
as a policy prescription I think this is
something that people should pay
attention to
California it's a very polluted part of
Southern California it's mostly Latino
community and so all of these Arab Iraqi
refugees have been placed in this Latino
immigrant community in Southern
California we don't know how that's
going to unfold you know so where people
get placed it does matter and are there
jobs in that community when people get
there I didn't really what we want to
say about New Haven New Haven's got
great refugee services because of iris
and I rap but in support community
overall New Haven we have to say that
and a lot of those people who've come
here the employment is maybe stable but
it's maybe not great employment so
you've got doctors working as hotel
maids and that sort of thing so we
really need to think about what we do to
create refugee problems and when we
bring refugees to our country how do we
take care of them at the final just my
final political comment a lot of
Vietnamese came to this country after
the Vietnam War the boat people there
was a huge influx of something like two
hundred and seventy-five thousand
Vietnamese came the u.s. gave them much
more support than the US has given to
Iraqi refugees they gave the Vietnamese
refugee population got three years of
subsidization until they could get off
they're off the ground and because they
were well supported as a refugee
population Vietnamese have done very
well in America there they have higher
rates of college attendance as there's a
general American public does something
like modal income household income for
the Vietnamese population is something
like fifty five thousand dollars
Vietnamese have been kind of a model
minority group because the u.s. gave a
lot of initial support and there's a
real critique of the Iraqi refugee
influx they didn't get near that amount
of support from the US government we've
really kind of failed in some ways the
overall Iraqi community we failed them
because we invaded the country and we
sort of failed Iraqis as a nation when
they get here so that's my pop those are
my politics thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]